make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin there
is a house in new orleans
they call the rising sun
and it's been the ruin of mania
poor boy oh god
i know i'm one
i love that song dude the animals were
amazing like
we gotta get out of this place if it's
the last thing we ever do
do like the animals were amazing how are
you guys doing
how are you guys doing this morning you
guys doing good
it's 9 15 a.m as i'm recording this and
we have reached it
the beginning of secret wars unanimously
you guys voted in the comments section
that you wanted to see me remaster
secret wars so we are remastering super
wars now here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna kick this off we're gonna
kind of skip secret wars issue number
zero because it's not really that
important we covered it last time around
but it's basically just the future
foundation right the little kids who are
building life raft
and that's basically it not really all
that relevant instead what we're gonna
do here is we're gonna kind of jump back
a little bit and we're gonna pick up
178 days before the final incursion now
a lot of you guys asked this question we
recorded this
we had captain america's mighty avengers
which had basically become captain
america secret adventures right steve
rogers secret avengers team and a lot of
guys are kind of asking
where's like how do blue marvel get
involved in all this and all that kind
of stuff and so what we end up doing
here is we pick up at the gym theater
which is where the mighty avengers
headquarters located now if you are
curious about how this team
formed as well as a lot of the members
that are in it uh you can find that in a
video down in the description uh it'll
basically be the the mighty avengers
video that we did
where doctor strange ended up basically
resurrecting schuma gorath or bringing
shumogorath into the marvel universe
right that was during the events of
infinity and that's where the mighty
avengers are
i guess the second version of the mighty
avengers reform but you got steve rogers
here and steve rogers basically
approached the group before the big
battle that we saw between the mighty
avengers the illuminati and amadeus
chose avengers team and he basically
basically explains to them that like the
multiverse is ending and so with all
this kind of being explained
by steve rogers and it's actually put
very succinctly in this this bit of an
explanation here right the way that al
ewing does it and i think it's probably
one of the easiest explanations to
understand right steve rogers explains
the incursions
as like you know being in the
supermarket and there's a pyramid of
cans and somebody pulls one of the cans
out from the bottom and the whole
structure comes crashing down
except instead of cans you're talking
about entire universes which is a really
good way to put the way the incursions
were going on because one of the
drawbacks to hickman as much as i love
his writing he can be a little wordy and
he can he'll use ten words when five
will do and so i think that's
kind of one of the downsides although i
still love his writing and so basically
it's kind of steve rogers explaining
like you know the illuminati
the issue that they have is that in the
beginning of all this i tried to use the
infinity gauntlet right and the infinity
gauntlet worked to stop that one
incursion but we destroyed all the gems
in the process except for the time stone
which started yanking me through time
but notice this the immediate response
of luke cage is wait wait wait so you're
telling me
that the illuminati have known about
this the entire time and so did you
right like you were part of that
original illuminati group now luke case
doesn't have the full story but the
response of of steve rogers is don't
judge me and it's one of these things
where he's kind of like well it's
different when i do it right but
remember the full story about all this
is that yes steve rogers originally knew
what was going on with the incursions
and he told the illuminati we can't
destroy worlds right like we have to
spare
innocent lives and it's kind of funny
because you know of course his mind was
wiped which is what he tells everybody
that's why i didn't tell you before
because i didn't know
until not too long ago when original sin
happened and these memories were
restored to me
but at the end of the day the mighty
avengers are kind of split right white
tigers like they're doing this to save
entire universes and the issue that
captain america has is
but like they're taking innocent lives
and the the reality of this and this is
an important thing to understand not
even trying to give steve rogers a hard
time or call him dumb or anything like
that the reality of this
is i think the illuminati made the right
call right like there comes a point when
you really have to make that choice and
that's the important thing here is steve
rogers takes the stance that like all
life is important
no it's not either right like not all
life is important that's just the way
that it is the big
argument that steve rogers had is that
in his mind he saw the illuminati and
and those guys becoming as bad
as the people they were fighting and
there is that that argument does kind of
go around
by this one that a lot of people really
have in the real world that when you're
fighting an enemy if you become as bad
as the enemy you're fighting
then ultimately you become that enemy
but that's not true right it's
machiavelli and it's like dating 101. if
you're struggling because of the fact
that you're struggling with like all the
bad boys taking the girls then learn to
be machiavellian
be a good guy but don't be afraid to
take some literature from the
the handbook on how to be a dick right
like don't become a terrible person
yourself but borrow their tactics from
time to time
and that's kind of what this required
right that's what this was it was
don't become a villain but don't be
afraid to use some of the tactics the
villains use so long as you keep your
eye on the prize you're not going to
lose your way and that's the biggest
issue with captain america is he was
always so narrow-minded and always so
focused on
always making sure they do the right
things that he didn't really seem to
understand the concept that sometimes in
order to do the right thing you got to
do some bad things
right that sometimes the ends really do
justify the means but because of that
again there's a kind of rift here in the
mighty avengers team
not everybody's on board and captain you
know steve rogers tells them make your
choice right either you can side with me
or you can side with them
but it's not going to be the same thing
now the other part of this is that the
team
kind of starts turning on sam wilson
because sam wilson also had knowledge of
this right remember captain america
is coming to them after he learned
everything and is kind of dumping this
information
but sam wilson knew before anybody else
in the mighty avengers knew and so the
fact that he didn't come to them and
tell them as part of their team
kind of pisses them off but one of the
things you kind of get here is you get
this sort of jumping forward through
days right from here we jump to 84 days
to live and what you basically end up
having here is essentially you know
volunteers for the mighty avengers
because remember unlike the main
avengers team where it's largely just
composed of superpowered beings the
mighty avengers was kind of a blend
between heroes for
hire and and the avengers team insofar
as you had the main mighty avengers
roster luke cage white tiger uh blue
marvel spectrum so on and so forth but
what you also had were basically people
were who were out there
trying to help the world and not
necessarily having superpowers and one
of the things that's kind of asked here
is is while the world is learning about
the incursions not everybody really sees
it as like
one of the biggest things in the world
right that at the end of the day like
you know yes the the universe in the
world is dying but like what are you
gonna do to stop it
on the other side of the equation you
have people who are kind of taking
political stances to this
you pick up with like 26 days before the
world ends and you have some political
pundits who are just like these are
terrorist planets right they're bad guys
they're enemies they're they're enemy
combatants and we have to treat them
that way right so you know warhawk hyper
hyper military those kind of guys you
know the ones that you don't really
listen to because they're you know
just disregard them but then you also
have like the ultra super progressives
right who were just like we gotta you
know help them and help them understand
that you know that we can see the
multiverse the other ones you don't
listen to either right like the people
on the extreme sides of the spectrum one
of the things you also get here is peter
corbeau
and peter corbeau is an old standing
member of really the x-men roster more
so than anything else he was just a
really really
old friend of charles xavier's but again
you know it's it's one of these things
where the other you know another major
issue that the the mighty avengers are
dealing with and something that kind of
flies under the radar are mass suicides
right people who are just like the world
is ending and instead of like facing the
world ending they just kind of take
their own life that the world is
responding to this in a multitude of
different ways now the the world's
response which is to say the average
human's response to this is actually
going to become an amazing talking point
once we get to like blue marvel right
like the the role that blue marvel plays
in all this but then you also have the
conspiracy theorists right the people
that you never listen
[Laughter]
the you to the guy who's like stanford
was an inside job you know and all that
kind of stuff is kind of like okay
whatever man like you know but
nonetheless you know you pick up with 19
days to live and this 19 days to live
is basically like the when the fight
began to break out between the
between captain america's avengers team
and like the illuminati but once we get
to 14 days to live this is when you end
up having like blue marvel stepping in
and this is a really really this is a
super cool moment here and this and
i was so glad to see it when i when i
saw it because i was like man dude it's
about time
somebody recognized this right so once
the battle's over
you've got the illuminati you know who
are talking to captain america but
you've got reed richards and black
panther who kind of stood to the side
and they were talking to blue marvel
and and you know reed richards kind of
says man like that's that was a that was
a crazy fight you know and it
probably could have ended a lot quicker
adam brashear because you were holding
back
and had you not been holding back you
probably could have ended
our whole movement pretty quickly right
he could have ended this all super fast
and
the kind of response that he says here
is you know having the avengers actually
talk to each other you know spectrum
says having our avengers talk to each
other is all we really wanted and then
in turn blue marvel's like yeah these
nonsensical squabbles
really have gone on too long and when
facing something like this we're vastly
stronger acting together than we are
apart and reid
takes that as kind of a heartening
response in the sense that blue marvel's
like yeah this guy finally understands
and the response of adam is
no you're totally misunderstanding reid
like i didn't say that because i think
you're making the right move here i'm
saying that because you're wrong you've
been wrong this entire time
and everything that's happened here has
been your fault from the very start and
black panther is kind of like no we've
been working on different things and i
assume you have too adam beshear you've
been trying to find a way to stop the
incursions and you haven't been able to
do it right nothing that you've been
able to work on has been able to stop it
and at the end of the day
spectrum's kinda like but you're still
not listening and and the question is
like why and adam brashear's response
was because you could have talked to all
of us
you could have talked to the rest of us
and hearing that come from adam bashir
really does kind of change things like
it kind of changes my perspective
because my initial response to this was
okay what good would it do to talk to
all these various superheroes out there
but the funny thing about this is adam
beshear
really is smart and i feel like adam
bashir having been left out of all that
is really kind of an
indication of two things one that in
marvel comics adam brashear is woefully
underrated he's painfully
underused but the other part of this is
that within the marvel universe he's not
really appreciated as a guy
is he one of the top 10 smartest people
in the world absolutely and it's kind of
a funny thing because he tells like
black panther and he tells reed richards
you should have talked to us
a lot of the people out there sure
they're not as smart as you are but you
literally have intelligent kids who are
helping you build a raft why because
kids have imagination because they think
about things that you wouldn't normally
be able to think of and
using that line of logic and then
canceling out all the other superheroes
makes no sense right it's kind of
nonsensical and it's a cool thing
because that's true because in response
you have black panther who says what
adam bashir
says that like have you ever considered
that the other seven billion of us
on the world might have liked to have
had a say in things the response of
black panther is have you asked them you
know like have you have you asked that
at all and that's actually a great point
to raise
because what you're seeing is that in
response to the end of the world there's
mass panic mass hysteria mass suicides
people are responding predictably and
that's
kind of justifies the illuminati's
actions you can't trust the average
person
with such a mind-blowing piece of
information because only two things are
going to happen either they're going to
refuse to believe it because it's just
not what they want to believe
or they're going to panic no real
constructive narrative can come out of
telling
seven billion people on the in the world
hey guys uh so the world is ending the
universe is ending too you can't tell
people that and so at this point we
transition away from that
and we jump directly into secret wars
number one we officially start secret
wars now remember this is the final
incursion between marvel's ultimate
universe and the main marvel universe
these are the last two worlds in
existence now something that i also want
to specify here a lot of you guys asked
the question early on in the story and i
don't remember if we answered this
already but a lot of you guys asked the
question early on in the story you said
okay
so what we have here are incursions we
have worlds crashing into each other if
two earths crash into each other it
wipes out both universes but if you
destroy one of the earth
then the universe that doesn't have an
earth just passes through the other
universe and nothing happens
right so all you have to do is destroy
one world and the day is saved so what
do we have like what about the universes
where those earths were already saved
where like those earths were either
destroyed by the superheroes who
resided in that universe right they
evacuated their earth they blew the
earth up and
saved their universe or the universes
were the earth were destroyed by the
other incursion
those universes should be okay and they
should be fine and they should be
floating around out there that's a very
very good question to ask and the answer
to that question came when doctor doom
unleashed the molecule men on the
beyonders right like
all that energy being being set off like
it was just like this massive
multiversal bomb and whatever universes
exist
out there were destroyed by that bomb in
the process leaving only the main marvel
universe and the ultimate universe now
the question you kind of have to ask
here
is why these two worlds are like why
these two universes like shouldn't they
have been destroyed in the process
sure but it's just storytelling and
that's basically it but the idea here is
that with the ultimate universe facing
off against the main marvel universe and
i like to consider the ultimate universe
the mcu i feel like it makes it a lot
more exciting but the kind of question
here that's being asked of nick fury of
the maker of this alternate reality
version of reed richards is how much
time do we have left
maker's response is okay normally we
would have eight hours from the time
that the incursive earth appears until
the time they collide but because of the
fact that there are no other universes
there because that's it
basically we have like an hour before
this incursion happens right so
literally they're just
flying towards each other and a lot of
this is really chalked up to the
explosion that led to the destruction of
all the other universes right
basically like this massive explosion
just pushed these two on a collision
course faster but whatever the logic
is the result is that they have an hour
before either both worlds end or one of
the worlds is destroyed the other part
of this
is that maker doesn't really tell nick
fury that there is no chance to win
but he doesn't tell him there's no way
for them to succeed he just kind of lets
nick fury believe that if they dispatch
the ultimates and all their helicarriers
from the triskelion into the
main marvel universe onto that earth
that like they can probably overpower
those heroes and they can probably take
the day
but thanos remember thanos and the cabal
are on the ultimate universe right
they're there with ultimate universe
reed richards and thanos asked the
question
why lie you know like why lie in the
midst of all this right i mean they
never really had a chance to win why not
just tell them that and the response of
read is because it wouldn't do any good
and when thanos says like everybody
deserves to know when their time is up
right people should know when there is
no chance for them to fight anymore and
just
give themselves over to death the
responsive read is it's not about that
it's about buying time that's all it is
these guys are cannon fodder
they don't know they're cannon fodder
but that's all they are right now switch
over to a couple things going on here
the first is the life raft of reed
richards right the main marvel universe
has its own life raft and that was reed
and valeria's answer to the idea of
not losing right they can't win but they
cannot lose and the only way to not lose
is to build a raft using materials made
of adamantium
vibranium and also using basically
material from the living tribunal itself
in order to
you know solidify this this vessel in
such a way to where it can navigate what
would be the multiversal space because
there are no materials out there that
exist in humanity that could survive the
crashing of two universes into each
other that's why the death of the living
tribunal was so important
because part of the living tribunal's
body can be used to reinforce this
vessel and ensure that it does survive
the crushing of these two universes
right now there are other things kind of
being thrown in there but the idea here
is that it's literally just grabbing as
many people as they possibly can because
the reality of this is that reading them
hoped that they could possibly stop the
incursions or at least stop this final
incursion but once this final incursion
started kicking off and then once the
ultimate universe
immediately dispatched their
helicarriers and all their different
superheroes to the main marvel universe
then it became apparent there's no
reasoning with these guys there's no
rationalizing with these guys all we can
do is basically stockpile as many
resources as we can
and just try to save the day the other
part of this is that they've also lost
scientists that in response to
everything that's going on
two of their of their specialists right
in chemistry and physics
decided to stay behind and be with their
families in the end of times now it's
not the biggest loss in the world and
reid even says they were basically
redundancies right they were backup
scientists so it's not the end of the
world that we don't have them you know
you also have like the x-men you have
beasts who left the x-men behind but the
big thing about this
is is there's two expected scenarios
between reed and t'challa and that's why
they have manifold remember manifold is
the guy eden who can teleport to
different locations or bring people to
him all he has to do is know that the
need is there and so the idea is that
one
they basically get you know everything
kind of goes as planned they launch
their resume
once with a resurrection team you know
and and that's it manifold teleports on
board and the day saved right so the
idea is that manifold is basically going
to reach out into the world and start
plucking out different superheroes from
where they are and say okay we'll bring
them here and then once all those
superheroes are brought here you know
protection roles different things like
that then basically manifold will
teleport back and they'll say okay guys
cool we got everybody let's go you know
and just ride off into the sunset the
worst case scenario
is that manifold saves the day but he
doesn't make it and
the funny thing about this is everything
that can go wrong is going to go wrong
right because the first thing that
happens here is you've got iron man from
the ultimate universe you know tony
stark who basically
tell him you know who flies to this
location and brings his entire weapons
platform with him and then of course he
faces off against carol danvers and
that's that's more or less that
you've got luke cage who's trying to
tend to the day as best they can
literally you have storm you have thor
who are using their powers to you know
take down one of the helicarriers and
that's really what's happening here
the forces of shield from the ultimate
universe are being
wildly overpowered because where the
ultimate universe was rooted more in
real life the main marvel universe was
rooted more in fantasy and so in a lot
of ways this is the answer to the
question
what would happen if the marvel
cinematic universe and the marvel comics
universe went to war with each other the
marvel cinematic universe would be
vastly overpowered they'd be wildly
overpowered and crushed by a huge margin
but the other thing is that
in the middle of all this sentinels come
flying in now the sentinels are
controlled by cyclops and nation x right
the x-men have arrived
and cyclops shows up here with the
phoenix egg and that's what's nuts is
because
in addition to whatever forces the
avengers have which are enough to
seemingly take out the helicarriers of
shield
now sentinels are here and these massive
sentinels start crushing everything now
the other part of this is that she-hulk
the incredible hulk colossus
nightcrawler they all start realizing
that all these are coming from a
particular vessel that they're all being
dispatched from this one particular ship
and the only way to really shut down
communications between like iron man and
the various you know ultimate characters
who are here on the main marvel universe
and the ultimate universe itself
is to destroy that vessel and that's
exactly what they do right you basically
end up getting the fastball special
which is normally colossus throwing
wolverine instead is colossus throwing
the incredible hulk since him flying up
into that vessel he basically destroys
or at least
attacks the the triskelion takes out the
scallions uh communication array and
that in turn cuts off their
communications to all the helicarriers
so now all the helicarriers out there
are not necessarily flying blind but
they can't talk back they can't call for
reinforcements or anything like that you
in turn end up having the maker
who finally launches his move and the
response to this is okay with the
triskelion down with all that being
sorted out
now it's time for us to basically launch
our final attack and so what ends up
happening is of course the dome starts
to open up now remember we talked about
this in in our video on ultimate read
right which you'll find down as part of
the best
comic book stories of all time playlists
down in the description but uh this
version of reid could
you know constructed this massive dome
where time time passed differently
time passed faster within the dome reed
himself made himself immune to it but
the idea was that basically time would i
think it was something like a thousand
years of evolution
took place inside this dome which means
that the the various weapon systems that
are that are here on this stone are a
thousand times more powerful than what's
already there
in the ultimate universe and so maker
ends up launching all these different
just
hyper advanced ships directly into the
main marvel universe the funny thing
about this
is that stowing away on one of these is
miles morales
[Laughter]
the miles morales you know during his
time as spider-man had come across all
this now a lot of that was explained in
miles more alice spider-man
going into secret wars going into this
but once these vessels arrive
they start unleashing holy hell like
literally just fire and brimstone just
raining it down on all the superheroes
and despite all their power like it's
obvious that this is basically the end
of it right like there's
no real way to come out on top here and
so what you end up getting is this
amazing moment right it's kind of a
small little moment but this amazing
moment those of you guys who read this
originally when we covered this
originally you guys know what's coming
what you end up getting here
is frank castle showing up right you've
got an email that's sent out by wilson
fisk the kingpin to all these various
villains that he's worked with over the
years and even some that he hasn't and
basically says like all of you i dreamed
of a glorious end right me standing over
the vanquish
as the world looked up in envy but it
seems time that fickle mistress has
robbed us
all of such an opportunity so i say this
if the world is truly ending
let it end thusly with drink and joy at
the sight of our enemies
greatest failure please join me for a
most raucous celebration
at the place where we met that time for
the thing i'm buying
sincerely wilson fisk all the various
villains show up here right and it's
considered to be a place where like
nobody can get access to nobody knows
about that's why he left this you know
kind of ambiguous message
that time for the thing that we did
right and so it's like okay cool so like
we're all gonna meet up at this one spot
and only the villains know about it now
while they're all enjoying their drinks
and they're watching the heroes fail and
they're watching these super advanced
weapons from the ultimate universe show
up and just start raining down fire and
brimstone and there's no real way for
the heroes to win
here comes frank castle and he says
gentlemen they say that when you die
you can't take it with you which begs
the question what exactly am i gonna do
with all these bullets he [ __ ] his gun
back
switch back to the battle right and it's
just like man that's amazing
it's so cool right so with all this fire
and brimstone raining down
immediately part of the resurrection
team is taken out right like part of
of uh reed richard's you know team is
gone it's it's kind of like okay so like
a lot of the resources that they had
here a lot of the things that they
needed
in order to resurrect themselves
properly are gone right there doesn't
really seem to be any real method of
resurrecting the heroes anymore black
widow
hawkeye these guys are all basically
dead and so in turn
it's kind of like you know black panther
tells tells uh tells manifold okay so
like time for plan two and so in
response
with everything going on manifold ends
up firing up right ends up using his
powers and while that happens he ends up
basically
you know snatching up all these
different characters star-lord gets
grabbed you end up having carol danvers
and thor who gets snatched away
spiderman peter parker gets snatched
away but while all that's happening
you have cyclops where the phoenix egg
finally hatches and he reaches inside
and basically imbues himself with the
entirety of the phoenix force and so
while all this fire and brimstone
brimstones being
being rained down by the ultimate
universe right with these these super
advanced ships that have been brought
there by the ultimate universe version
of reed
suddenly cyclops emerges with the
phoenix and it's dead right it's just
lights out it's just boom boom boom boom
boom
ship after ship after ship just gets
annihilated right like the vast power of
the phoenix force like and so with that
like in that moment it's like okay you
know cyclops is teleported aboard by
manifold they have everybody that they
need and the responsive read is
go like we have to get out right like
it's obvious we can't stop this
incursion there's nothing we can do here
the ultimate universe does the exact
same thing and launches their ship as
well cyclops is teleported aboard with
the full totality of the phoenix force
and they
bail right they're just like go like
they launch the ship fly into the
incursion point right the point between
these two
worlds where they're getting ready to
collide the issue with this is that the
worlds are literally being ripped apart
by title forces right they're within the
roche limit right those are guys who
don't know what that is
whenever you see a movie like like for
example if anything guys ever saw
melancholia and if you never did look up
the ending for it well there's a point
where like a giant world that's about i
don't know maybe four or five times the
size of earth crashes into the earth the
reality is that wouldn't happen and even
right now what you have is two world two
earth crashing into each other
that's not really what would happen
right they wouldn't actually impact each
other
what would end up happening is the title
forces of these worlds would pull
themselves apart
and that's what would that's what would
take place right if you had a planet
that was four times the size of earth
that was creating towards earth you'd
get to the roche limit which is the
point where the gravitational pull of
that world is so intense
that it would literally start ripping
the earth to pieces right it would just
start ripping out huge chunks of the
planet physics and science is crazy but
the idea is that they end up flying in
between the uh and in between the
incursion point which seems to be the
best place for them to be the problem
with this is all these massive storms
and all this craziness going on one of
the gravitational uh
gravitational attacks ends up ripping
off a portion of the life raft right
which contains
susan storm valeria and franklin
richards and because
all of this happens so incredibly fast
that with with susan johnny storm like
with basically every every member of
reed's family except for himself right
like it's literally like ben graham
susan storm
johnny storm uh franklin and valeria he
does what he can right like susan
basically fires up her force field to
keep them from like disintegrating into
the into the space of nothingness
essentially and so you end up having
like this shield that immediately comes
up in response to that right you know
around the lifecraft and so it reads
like t'challa left the shield down and
he's like dude if we do that it's going
to crush everything right like right now
the shield capacity is at 92
i can do this read but if i open this
door and shield like shield integrity
gets below 90
i have to close it back otherwise we're
gonna lose everything and the responsive
read is that's all i need right so this
door takes
five seconds right the shield takes five
seconds to open right so you've got reed
richards standing there right like
standing standing on this edge
just waiting waiting to like reach out
and grab this vessel and yank it back in
within the uh within the life raft right
so you got reed stand in there you've
got susan storm using her force field
and holding this entire thing together
right now one thing to understand
susan storm is not just holding this
together her force field is holding off
the collapse of a universe she's
literally
holding two universes apart with her
force field but in this moment you
basically get this countdown right you
get five you get
four three two the shield starts to come
undone you get to one the shield totally
fails susan storm franklin valeria
johnny storm ben grimm are just
yanked away right they just disappear
into nothingness and there's nothing
reed can do
he loses his entire family in that
instant the world's collide and what's
left of the multiverse
has totally been destroyed the only
survivors of this multiversal collapse
are those who were in the ultimate
universe life raft those who were in the
life raft in the main marvel universe
and they're only protected by the energy
they use from the living tribunal to
kind of create that shield
and the only other people there are the
molecule man owen reese
dr steven strange and doctor doom the
end of the marvel universe has happened
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob corp if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
laughs
you